i'm in grund hayden near berlin where
elon musk is gearing up to beat the
german automakers at what they're best
at
perfect in car manufacturing
tesla already leads on batteries and
softwares but when it comes to actually
making the car the common belief was
that the german automakers vw and bmw
would quickly beat the new upstart
because of their superior manufacturing
chops
elon musk believes he can prove them
wrong and he'll do it right here in
their backyard
the plant which musk hopes will start
producing model wise before the end of
the year is supposed to revolutionize
car production by churning out an ev
three times faster than his german
rivals can if musk can deliver he'll
take giant strides toward more
affordable evs further threatening the
mass market manufacturers
key to his plan is the gigapress several
vast die casting machines each weighing
about three times as much as the statue
of liberty these machines take molten
aluminum to spit out much of the chassis
in a single piece thus removing the need
for 200 industrial robots and a 60 part
assembly
tesla also designed a new battery pack
linking the cars front and rear on the
bodies so instead of a pack that's
bolted to the chassis with lots of metal
parts it instead functions as a key
structural element of the vehicle that
makes production faster and the car
lighter resulting in a bigger range and
finally tesla says its paint job is
unique because it can apply 13 layers of
varnish thinner than a human hair there
are risks to mast efficiency push
he has said that tesla will be trying
lots of new tech at queen hider and he
has warned of significant production
risks because of it
also tesla is still waiting for final
approval from local authorities for the
site
german car makers are nevertheless
watching very closely what happens here
in greenheider and some are already
preparing to strike back volkswagen has
said it wants to build a new eevee
factory in wolfsburg at its headquarters
to make 250 000 cars a year and it wants
to catch up with tesla on production
time
still if musk succeeds here at
clenheider this factory could be the
benchmark for ev production for some
time this is how we move i'm stefan
nicola for more contact like this follow
us on your favorite platforms